via di andrea di vermisst vermisst vermisst ihn
Ich vermisse, was wir versuchen könnten
zusammen 14. April 2000 gehen an die
sehr sonnig Person sehr sonnig
nicht so einfach, viel zu streiten
empfindlich, obwohl ein Mensch mit Herz, aber
auch bei der Arbeit sowieso eine Person
auch sehr beliebt bei der Arbeit in
Auswirkungen, wenn vielleicht Antwort von
Vorarbeiter war nicht da, er hat sich auch darauf verlassen
viel zu ihm
Er ist so Gesellschaft des feindlichen Volkes
er ist viel sonniger als ich, muss ich sagen
die viel sonnigere Wahrheit weist er zurück
unser Schatz fehlt so sehr
plötzlich und tragisch, wie es uns zeigt
Wir wissen, dass er jeden von uns verlassen hat
in Bestürzung
er ist mein leben sowieso er ist das
das erlaubte mir, darin zu bleiben
Welt, weil ich denke, wenn es nicht wäre
Ich war schwanger, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es geschafft hätte
dass meine Eltern du für mich tun musst
meine Schwiegereltern Kinder müssen Sie für die tun
Baby und er muss dir nur sagen, dass meins ist
gab mir mein Leben zurück
Ich bin nicht schlecht in dem Sinne, wenn ich zurückdenke
Ich kann sagen, ich habe genug getan
und so andrea diese andrea ist so